in the United States the government's
top infectious disease expert has
sounded the alarm about the rapid spread
of the corona virus dr. Anthony Fauci
says that the number of daily cases
could more than double if the country
fails to contain a surge in infections
across several states another bleak
warning from the experts speaking to
lawmakers in Washington the message
couldn't be clearer I'm very concerned
about what's going on right now
particularly in the four states that are
accounting for about 50% of the new
infections but the other vulnerable
States so I'd have to say the numbers
speak for themselves I'm very concerned
and I'm not satisfied with what's going
on because we're going in the wrong
direction the states he's referring to a
Florida Arizona Texas and California
they've seen infection surge forcing
governor's to wind back efforts to
reopen their economies states that bore
the brunt of the virus early and making
quarantine mandatory for new arrivals
are vulnerable divided between former
and current virus hotspots we can't just
focus on those areas that are having the
surge it puts the entire country at risk
we are now having 40 plus thousand new
cases a day I would not be surprised if
we go up to a hundred thousand a day if
this does not turn around
dr. fat cheese was just one in a chorus
of concerned voices who say not enough
Americans are social distancing or
wearing masks unfortunately this simple
life-saving practice has become part of
the political debate that says this if
you're for Trump you don't wear a mask
him you're against Trump you do that's
why I've suggested that the president
occasionally wear a mask the Republican
urged the president to set a better
example for many the stakes are too high
for any political stigma surrounding
masks
from the u.s. to the Czech Republic now
where people have been celebrating a
perceived end to the coronavirus crisis
in their country with a massive public
dinner party in the capital now large
crowds gathered on Prague's charles
bridge on tuesday and sat down to dine
at a gigantic 500 meter table the
country has by now eased most
restrictions which had been introduced
fairly early on in the pandemic the
Czech Republic registered fewer than
12,000 coronavirus cases and under 350
deaths brazil's army has been testing
isolated indigenous communities for the
coronavirus on this visit no one tested
positive but the pandemic is threatening
to decimate hundreds of Amazon tribes
they have a little immunity to external
diseases and have a communal lifestyle
that rules out social distancing
authorities in northwestern Germany are
preparing to ease the strict to lockdown
imposed in some districts after a kovat
19 outbreak flared at a beet processing
factory their people have been ordered
to stay in their homes and are banned
from traveling anywhere for many of
those who have seen quarantine returned
patience is wearing thin but testing who
is healthy and who is not is a major
challenge these employees of the Tania's
meat processing plant and other
residents want out about 650 people have
been restricted to this block on the
outskirts of Farrell a city of 25,000 in
western Germany they've been placed
under quarantine but this is set to
change the mayor is preparing to lift
the quarantine gradually but he still
faces one big obstacle trying to figure
out who is who and who is healthy there
are different lists of people who are
actually living there and people who
should be there but probably left before
the quarantine who've likely headed home
I met many in feral and in the
neighboring larger city of Gutierrez lo
also want out after all
it's summer vacation but numerous German
holiday resorts will only accept
travelers from high-risk locations if
they've tested negative for the
coronavirus this temporary testing
facility is being run with the help of
soldiers from the German army every day
we test over 700 people here honestly
we've yet to see a positive test that's
some good news for a change
good news but people here are still
angry especially at the management of
the Chinese meat plant which was ground
zero for a fresh outbreak of the
pandemic in this region it's their fault
the meat plant acted incredibly
irresponsibly the police and the city
need to come down hard on them for now
the city has its hands full it has to
decide who may and may not be released
from quarantine workers have to check
people against lists of those who've
been tested it's still going to take
quite some time weeks maybe months until
we're done with everything it will
likely also take a long time until we
finally have a vaccine or drugs to treat
the illness until then
local residents will have to live with
lockdown restrictions and here are some
of the other developments in the corona
virus pandemic the German state of
Bavaria is to bring in universal testing
for Cova 19 it's prompted a debate about
whether the rest of Germany should
follow suit or stick to targeted testing
to prevent a possible second wave
coronavirus deaths will soon top 60,000
in brazil the worst kit hit country
after the United States the army has
delivered protective supplies and
medicines by helicopter to indigenous
communities in the Amazon Thailand has
begun a fifth phase of relaxations of
restrictions schools and high-risk
entertainment venues such as bars and
massage parlors have been allowed to
reopen and China has reported just three
new cases of corona virus compared to 19
the day before all the new cases were in
Beijing the EU has opened its external
borders to leisure and business travel
today but not to all countries
oh no virus hotspots including the US
and Russia were excluded from the
so-called
safe list of countries whose residents
can enter the bloc Australia Japan and
South Korea did make the cut however
Chinese travelers can also enter but
only after China opens its own borders
it's a difficult summer for tourism
dependent businesses in Europe with more
EU residents staying close to home
Chelsey Delaney is on the story for us
she joins us now from Frankfurt so what
is the reopening mean for the EU
well this reopening is really crucial
for the European economy as you said
there are a lot of countries that are
extremely dependent on on travelers from
abroad so especially countries like
Greece or Italy they they get a lot of
their their revenue from trip from
travel especially in this summer travel
season so the lack of travel has really
impacted a lot of people and a lot of
businesses but this is also a bit of a
disappointment for those dependent
people because this doesn't include the
United States which about a 15 million
people travel from the u.s. to to the EU
every year so that's a big loss of
revenue and it also doesn't include
Brazil Russia countries like that so
it's not a total relief for some of
these from for some of these businesses
you are at the Frankfurt Airport right
now what precautions are being taken
there
so a big part of the the safety measures
here at the airport are everyone has to
wear a mask there are disinfecting
stations located at throughout the
airport but a lot of it is really
signage so there are a lot of signs
there are a lot of announcements every
few minutes saying please wear a mask
there aren't there aren't really any
things like temperature checks things
like that that we've seen at other
airports they do have two testing
centers here where you can get tested
for corona virus one of them opened
earlier this week but you do have to pay
for them yourself and you also have to
wait a little while to get the results
so I think it's written in general a
pretty light a level of safety measures
here at the airport
Chelsea Delaney in Frankfort thank you